え音に耳ははじめ雪をです本当ですねー
あのもうお気づきの方も多いと思うんですけどもうお腹ないか普通の人はしないような
ことを
最近ちょっとしてしまいまして
まあ端的に言いましょう記憶喪失です
ビッグガンぐらいまで僕動画だしたんですよあの技能がついに一つに地上最強のシャー
ペン現れつってチャットや場でこう
シャーペンらっしゃるどこだったんですよ twitter とか穴が youtube
のコメント欄で何か不思議なポイントがたくさん来てるなぁと思ってよく見てみると
あ
やれペン地球は世界じゃない初めにこれ目指すにあったことあるよとか
始めあれこれ前もやったような気が合うと思って払って思っていやいやぽレンズがを
連続な高機能になってどれ見たことなくてすごいと思ったから静雄作業のシャーペンで
して商売したのにと思ったらアーマーン前に全く同じことをやってみました
デイ完全に記憶喪失でやばいよだけだと所で誰かかぶったなら共かけ北自分の動画の
ネタがかぶったわけですよやばいもう本当に
マッキーナ負けない本当に山にする会2年前じゃん2年前と被ってるんだよ2年前棚札
版には瀬谷蓮れんはさすがに寝させてに自分やったことははすると思うんだよちょうど
2年前だなぁ
22か続けてられる
パパ待って
すごい三日画師ても全く同じことを言ってるここが尖ってるから結構背付かセラね
やはりしづ用シャーペンよりのこのちょっと出てる感じでペンテルさんが出せる
サーフィンの最高峰クラスのシャーペンらしいですあなたのぺんてる最高峰のさっ
ペースローナーで最高峰ガロが歯が折れないをレンズ数無限に書き続けることができる
機能が合体し
あのがをレンズれるらしいですターン芯が折れなくて1回ノックするだけで園に書き
続けられるもう最強のシャーペンだしてスマッシュを彷彿させる書やさですねなんか
個人的なしまっしゅな感覚を感じることができましたてネロっていう言葉はイタリア語
で黒って三大性です
雨ロッテ黒って話でてイタリア語でこんなん使ったらまずもうもてるぜ黒いシャープ
脳とか言ったらどうすれば女の子のみんなこれでしょやろ俺狙わせを出さないで書く
シャープペンシルです
をレンズで炉心を出さないで各社2点するでしまーすごぃ3日前に出せずでもなく
スマッシュ
並みに書きやすいてみればぶりに出て2年前には全く同じことを言ってるんですよ
スマッシュために書きやすいって
[音楽]
は全く同じ事言ってる黒い者で惚れるって言うことは全く同じこと言ってる
こんなん使ったらまずもうもてるぜめっちゃかっこいいじゃんこれくらいシャーペンの
音が入ったらどうすれば女の子のみんなこれでしょ
やろ
いやすごいは自分で見て触れたんだけども
本当に狙ってるんですよ3日前は本気でオレンズでのめっちゃにシャーペンじゃ紹介
しようと思ってをレンズの機能と書き続けられる機能型されてすごいなぁと思ったのを
そのまま言ったら2年前に全く同じことを言ってるっていう
[音楽]
俺やばいかななんかドアせるとかの次元じゃないんだよな完全にノーミスから抜けてる
んだよな
いやビビったマジで今改めて2年前のみたんですけど言っている事がほとんど一緒
ほんとに一緒
[音楽]
ええええええ
俺大丈夫かなたばんやっぱねこうあの僕も youtube 行ってきてもう67年
経ってるわけですよ俺動画な本獲ったんだろうメインチャンネルでもに専門近くとって
さべでも1000本撮ってるんでも3000本動画を3000本骨をとっていると
いよいよこういうことが起きるなっていう気がしましたね
もうあとですね僕ら前
言われるんですよあった人にね一さんはじめさんはじめはじめ
あの動画をする買った米を映画なんですかって聞いたらなんとか落ちた動画ってれても
思い出せないんですよなんかなんでだろうなあ俺やばいんかな
ワンちゃんには行きますよ動い記憶に残ったでめっちゃくちゃ言いたかったら
めちゃくちゃ大変だったり何かしらので会員証があったら覚えてるんですけども興味
本位でさらってて
動画に関してはもうほぼ覚えてないんですよ今回のシャーペンの動画に関しても多分
興味本位でシャー芯が折れナイスチャーシーンがもうドックして来て続けるしああ
すげえと思って純粋に行ったからこそ当たり前のようにやりすぎで記憶になかった
みたいな感じなのかなっていう気がしております
高は約二ずれた街で抹茶9わからなかったらこんなこと面白くてやる人いないと思うん
ですよだと
同じことやってんだもんネタ投下で同じ打たれ頑張ったんだからありそうなんですけど
家商品紹介で同じの全く同じようにやるっていうこともないですからねつまんないから
良木やってるわけなんで自分
怖いなって思いますか youtube で17年ぐらいになるとペターが自分と
かぶりますユーチューバーの皆さん是非覚えておいてくださいあの今後もこういうこと
がないように気をつけるんですけどももしかぶったらあいつまた脳みそがいかれてるな
と思って生暖かい目で見てやってくださいまあ
ちなみに3日前とってサーフィンの動画はシャー芯が0.3のシャーペンで年前にとっ
てサーフィンは写真が0.2のシャーペンなので
霧違う
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ